[Music]
yeah I think the most important part of
any CEO running a major global
corporation is to be on the ground in
those geographies to the extent that he
or she is able to do so and also to
build a team a trusted advisory team
which is having ongoing communications a
good case in point would be Alan Mulally
at Ford when he took over in a very very
tumultuous time in the auto industry he
established his own world room everyone
on deck around the globe on screens
around the around the world to weigh in
on challenges opportunities and he had a
grading system green light yellow light
red light not not too difficult to
understand in concept but he would go
around and ask each one of the leaders
around the world whether things were
going really well if there was a yellow
light if there was some caution and a
red light indicating that there were
problems that needed to be addressed if
someone especially during the calamitous
period of time that Ford was going
through if someone gave a green light
which were all prone to try to do
especially near performance appraisal
time he would typically ding them by
saying wait a minute we all need help
nothing is ever perfect so tell us how
we can help you in a collaborative way
around the world to support you and by
the fifth or sixth meeting virtually
everyone was giving yellow and red
lights and what that did was it forced
employees the executive senior
executives from every corner of the
globe to not be afraid to ask for help
and to acknowledge that they needed help
and and the fear factor of a the next
performance evaluation went away because
they recognized that if they were asking
for help they would get rewarded and in
fact over a period of time this
cross-cultural collaboration began to
develop and grow and people whether it
be from China or Singapore Malaysia won
Hong Kong Buenos Aires Mexico City or
New York City they began to speak
effectively with the same tongue no
clearly language is interpreted
differently around the world so there
typically would be at least the second
or third translation of what was
actually implied or meant in those
discussions but over time that team
develop a sense a bonded collaborative
spirit and they were rewarded
economically for working together
[Music]
you